we talk all the time about the envy of
being a global game Dave McMenamin is on
right now Dave did you know this the NBA
champions from Toronto the MVPs from
Greece the most improved players from
Cameroon the Rookie of the Year is
Slovenian and the Defensive Player of
the Year is from France the NBA truly is
a global game Dave Oh fantastic and Mike
Budenholzer from Arizona blood in the
game as well but it was it really was a
tremendous night and the idea that
someone can have a manifest destiny
journey like Yanis that's kupo it's
inspiring it quite frankly there's no
other word for it you you're in a room
last night and Adam silver gets up and
he says you know there's only been about
4,000 people in the history of the NBA
so where Jersey to play in this league
and you realize how specialized it is
just to get to that level and then to
win an MVP in the you know one of the 73
in this league's history or I guess is
even less because I've repeated you know
it takes an incredible amount of
determination and you know the tears
pouring down the honestest face when
he's talking about you know there were
days where you know I didn't want to
play or days I felt sore and you know I
did it you know my memory of my dad I
did it for my teammates and you know
it's easy to criticize guys easy to say
oh yeah he's so lucky
you know he's born with a 7-foot
wingspan and and this incredible
athleticism and yeah we can't even shoot
a three-pointer oh my gosh but folks
about what you can actually do it's a
really really special guy and a special
story yeah Chris Brockman sitting in for
Rich Eisen and Ryan Holland here on the
Rich Eisen show talking with Dave
McMenamin ESPN it's the Honda inside a
report brought to you by the Honda
fourth-of-july sales event right now you
can enjoy monumental offers on the
Accord pilot and civic sedan Korean and
cast your vote for great deals today you
were there last night Dave what was the
scene like when Yana TSA's name was
announced there in Santa Monica well he
was rolling deep he had his brothers
there I think they go by the cou pros
and
Milwaukee Bucks we're out in full force
several grocery staff members as well as
John horses general manager and he had a
great night - he was named executor of
the year you know they took home a lot
of hardware between the three of them
with blood get in coach of the year as
well and you know everybody stood up and
you know there was I'd say that three
moments of the night there was the Robin
Roberts award yes she was presented with
the Craig Sager honour there was magic
and bird up there and it was the honest
and they no disrespect to Luca and all
the other guys have won awards but those
were those were the moments where the
entire crowd got up to their feet the
crowd I've never really been to an
awards show before so maybe this is what
it's like but during every commercial
break the crowd got up and everybody's
going to the bar what kind of needles
around right everyone main yeah I would
say it was it was a distracted crowd for
most of the night but you could hear a
pin drop during Alice's speech that was
kind of the moment where you know you
can't not pay attention to the guy you
know everyone in that building at some
extent has a connection to basketball or
respect for basketball and and for
someone to kind of pour his heart out
like that what was remarkable I got to
talk to you on us afterwards and in my
mind was that in today's NBA for better
for worse you see guys playing with one
another in the summertime going on
vacations together you know and he's
been the lone wolf and purposely not
done that and you know he rattled off a
quick list of you know the six or seven
guys that he thought were the best of
the game is if I played against them I'm
sure like I picked something up you know
playing a squire LeBron or Kevin Durant
and on and on sometimes but the way I've
done it it's worked for me and guess
what I get to come back every year with
the surprise to the game and to me that
was almost him being like hey you like
this version of me wait until next year
yeah wait till he develops a 22 foot
jumper a three-point shot he famously
turned down a role in space GM - right
yes he did it would disturb his training
schedule yeah but that's not what I'm
about that's also why I turned down a
row in space to him - Jeanne bus made
some news
last night Dave just give us a second
we're gonna play her sound from the red
carpet talk about Magic Johnson well
since you know the end of the season I
had a big surprise when Magic Johnson
decided to step down and so we've had a
lot of changes but I'm very confident
and Rob Kalinka leading our basketball
operations kind of been the first time
we've heard her publicly address magic
surprise surprise move stepping down
what is your reaction to hearing that
yeah I mean I think she handled herself
well and she's all about trying to put
the best spin and the best foot forward
for the franchise that she cares so
dearly about bye after later I was like
hey what about this the timing though I
mean the day you guys are introducing
Frank Bulbasaur head coach Magic goes on
national television I gotta burn into
your place to the ground oh you know
I've known magic for so long he's always
full of surprises and this reminds me of
that 1981 where you know you surprised
by wanted to get Paul Weston fired and
guess what we ended up with Pat Riley so
who knows maybe this will turn out to be
just the thing we needed
I was like okay Jeannie I mean yeah
you're buying that are you no not at all
but I mean I do respect that she's gonna
protect her her franchise at all cause I
mean cuz that was two-and-a-half months
ago that magic walked into Staples and
kind of surprised everyone why do you
think it's taken so long for her to
address this I really believe that they
had a strategy or they continued to have
a strategy that there are close quarters
and you know loose lips sink ships and
we're gonna let our work through talking
so let's let's make an Anthony Davis
trade that's you know button up the rest
of the roster and then come you know
July then we'll address everything now
you know a few was down out there
yesterday she said she was there to
support magic because magic got this
Lifetime Achievement Award that was the
explicit reason for her being there to
me that again is a strong move it it
says that you know our relationship is
more than what just happened a couple
months ago
it's decades long and this is you know a
special achievement for someone who has
been great for
they are franchised with the entire NBA
but you know it as a reporter it's been
somewhat frustrating because you know
the words have been few and far between
from Rob palinka and certainly from
Jeannie but so now what is one of the
Lakers doing we're a less than a week
away from free agency klay Thompson I
presume they were targeting is going to
be out for most of next year so who are
their big fish that they're going after
yeah I mean cake lady months ago I'm
sure would have been right at the top of
list but you know they have a Titan
window because LeBron is gonna be 35
years old play in the year 17 and so you
look at the table it's going to be Kawhi
Leonard first and then you know in some
order behind that Jimmy Butler Kyrie
Irving it and I'm not even sure Kemba
Walker would be on that list you know
there at some point they're gonna look
at it and say whatever money we can free
up and it could be right now it's about
24 million that could get up to 32
million through various machinations
that should be feasible for them to do
is it worth to pay that guy temel walker
32 million or at that level that's the
top-tier talent we get to would it be
better to split it up and you know
become June 30th this Sunday they'll
know for sure you know I don't think
most guys are gonna drag their feet with
their answers and things go pretty
quickly in free agency these days so
know for sure whether they're and I've
shot it that's one of the big guys and
if they don't in short order they look
to split it up and it's kind of the top
three priorities explained to me here
big man shooter and point guard and you
know a name to look at point guard it's
darren collison a couple names to look
at at the sure position or you know
Danny Green JJ Redick and even
Kentavious caldwell-pope who's I've been
on a couple of one of your deals are
represented by rich Paul just like
anything Davis and LeBron James and
Center yeah it wouldn't surprise me if
you saw you know Tyson Chandler and
Orangevale McGee come back I think the
big fish that like it's a real and would
be DeAndre Jordan
yeah we're seeing DeAndre Jordan's name
rumor
to try to lure a Kevin Durant to
Brooklyn is that still in play I mean
what are the Nets chances are the
betting favor to get Kevin Durant are
they going to land him and/or Kyrie
Irving and someone else yeah I've seen
the backside you know I saw the reports
and the New York Times on DeAndre Jordan
I can't speak to the realistic
possibility I mean one thing I know
speaking to some people familiar with
the Nets everyone
I shouldn't say everyone a lot of people
around that situation believe Kyrie
Irving's coming and so that's the first
domino and the question is and we've
seen different reporting we've seen the
reporting actually kind of change you
know the messaging a month ago is that
yeah we'd be totally cool with Kyrie
Irving and D'Angelo Russell as are
playing in the backboard I can't see
that working I can't either and and now
you're hearing well you know this is not
my reporting the port's that are out
there maybe there's some trepidation
about bringing a Kyrie unless Katie's
coming with them and it may be you know
maybe the DeAndre Jordan pieces you know
maybe Tyree isn't enough of a geologist
himself but if we can say we're gonna
add Kyrie and DeAndre to play with you
that will bring comes around and I mean
it's fascinating I think the position
that both the Clippers and the Nets have
done and having a bunch of young talent
that consider relatively egoless and
then you have a very confident in deep
front office and money to spend I mean
that's the formula to get this thing
done and and whether you know both of
them get there their biggest fish they
dream of to Katie for the nets and Kauai
for the Clippers I think both those
franchises are set up to have a lot of
success over the next half decade or so
you mentioned Kawhi Leonard news just
broke earlier this morning that Masai
Ujiri is going to stay in Toronto
turning down a reported offer from
Washington what does that mean to
possibly getting Kawhi to resign in
Toronto I think it would be a good son
but I'm not gonna get inside quite that
because I don't
I can't do it I you know from what you
saw and when you observe them during the
parade or or you know after press
conferences and then seeing them you
know cher hugger and then you know
obviously the way Masai speaks in such
reverent tones about Hawaiian and
obviously Hawaii to see that hey this
guy had a bold strategy to trade for me
and make me feel as comfortable as
possible and so that all those things I
think we work in at right direction but
you know he's the SoCal native and then
if that really is a top priority for him
like no matter what Maasai does unless
he trades for the beach will trade you
this hour yeah I don't think that you
can be but doesn't a one plus one for
Kauai makes sense when you look at the
bucks out of a ton of free agents not
not sure who's gonna come back to them
the Celtics are in a little bit of
disarray you don't know who's coming
back to Philadelphia they could run back
to our whole team and make another run
at this now oh yeah I mean yeah you
would say that some of their key pieces
Kyle Lowry
Marc Gasol Serge Ibaka are probably on
the descent now you would say that okay
Pat got the Octomom nice and friendly
getting better they didn't have oh she
has an OB throughout the entire playoff
run because he had to have protected me
you know there's this enough to talk
yourself into them being a favorites
especially because quite so good but I
you could probably say that he could
find himself another core out there
where he would have a better mix of
players all getting better versus some
key pieces that are kind of on the
decline all right Dave thirty seconds
one of my Celtics doing they're making
sure they got a bunch of good kids with
good character my goodness to me when
you're talking about that you're not
yeah of course we you gotta like Tatum
and brown still and and you know Hayward
showed a little bit at the end of last
season but they've moved in my mind
they've moved out at contender status
and there'll be a playoff game that's so
frustrating
I mean I'm available right you've seen
my game Dave you called me last wee
so Danny needs the county report thank
Chris boat all right that's our Honda
inside a report brought you by the on a
fourth of July sales of n right now you
can join monumental offers from the
Accord pilot in Civic Sedan hurry and
cast your vote for great deals today
Dave McMahon event of ESPN foam on
Twitter at MC te n Dave you're the best
thanks bud - for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app